conservatives are right about everything
we're right about everything and when we
say things we're called idiots and Rubes
and ignoramuses and uneducated and and
then 6 months to two years later we're
proven right about every single thing in
this case the stupid paper
straws everything we're right about the
co vs we're right about the lockdowns
we're right
about human life and borders and the
economy and all of those issues but but
even down to the stupid paper straws do
you remember when a 9-year-old in Canada
had a school project where he called up
some straw companies and then
extrapolated the data data quote unquote
he got from a handful of straw companies
out to a whole nation and then made this
claim that we're wasting a bazillion
gazillion tons of plastic every minute
and then the liberal activists decided
to run with this little kid as the face
of environmentalism and then got all of
the restaurants to take away our straws
and force us to to drink our iced
coffees out of those paper things that
turn to just pulp and mush within three
sips so you can't you just can't drink
your coffee remember when that happened
over the Last 5 Years well it turns out
the paper
straws are not safe for the
environment the whole reason we did that
they they are not better at bringing
your drink into your mouth they're not
not more convenient they're not cheaper
they're not any of those things the
entire reason that we did it was because
a nine-year-old told us that the plastic
straws were bad for the environment and
that the paper straws were good for the
environment well the paper straws are
bad for the environment new study shows
that there are toxic chemicals in there
according to this study the straws
contain poly and per floro alkal
substances bfas which are long lasting
potentially destructive to human health
but who cares about that and we've got
to prioritize the Delta smelt over human
beings these days they're also bad for
the environment according to Dr teimo
Gren from the University of antp straws
made from plant-based materials such as
paper and bamboo are often advertised as
being more sustainable and eco-friendly
but the pfas in there means that is not
necessarily the case they looked at 39
different straw bands and it turns out
that they're all pretty pretty bad for
the environment yeah of course of
course this always happens we're always
proven right about these things and so
here's my recommendation I've made this
recommendation on the show before with
regard to totally different kinds of
issues my recommendation
is be normal you should Endeavor at all
times in your life to be
normal this is true in your work it's
true in your private life it's true in
your your relationships it's true it's
true even in the straws you
drink how anybody could
conclude that grinding up a bunch of
industrial made pulp and H upending the
entire beverage industry in 5 seconds is
going to be good and there was going to
be no consequence to that is just crazy
just be normal this is the consequence
of rationalism in politics and people
thinking that their their own very small
stock of reason unfettered from
tradition or Eternal principles or
anything else is sufficient to remake
Society into a wonderful Utopia it never
happens and when it comes to the straws
nobody really cares it's a minor
inconvenience and maybe it's slightly
bad for the environment but again we
were using plastic before so who really
cares but but this can have far more
deleterious effects for human beings as
we're seeing in a very very similar kind
of study with regard to the n95 masks
that all of the experts from the liberal
establishment including
conservative commentators told us to
wear for years turns out those aren't so
great either right now go to Pur
talk.com is your cell phone in desperate
need of replacement you know the signs
short battery life so you got to have a
charger on hand cracked screen that
gives you a little glass splinters well
it's time to put that old phone to rest
and upgrade to a new 5G Samsung Galaxy
from Pure Talk for free get a free 5G
Samsung Galaxy with 2-day battery life
edgo Edge display and Ultra strong
Gorilla Glass when you sign up for p
talks unlimited talk text and 15 gig
data plan for just 35 bucks a month plus
it comes with a mobile hotspot if you
are not using pure talk you are simply
paying too much get all the data you
could ever need for half the price of
the big carriers on America's Most
Dependable 5G Network go to Pur talk.com
nscw for your free super durable 5G
Samsung Galaxy when you switch to P talk
that is Pur
talk.com then make the switch to my cell
phone company that would be P talk the
official Wireless partner of the daily
wire thought the straws were bad new
study out shows that the n95 coid
masks May expose wearers to dangerous
levels of compounds that are toxic and
linked to
seizures and
cancer initially we were told that the
masks just the stupid little hankies
were going to stop you from getting coid
then the experts admitt that wasn't true
then we were told no no no it's not
supposed to stop you from getting Co
those stupid masks are supposed to stop
you from spreading coid then we found
out that wasn't true then we were told
well no the hanky masks that you were
forced to wear for a while they don't
actually do anything but the n95 masks
those are the good
ones even conservatives got duped by
this said well look we all know the
hankes don't do much but the n95 those
are great cuz some other expert told me
that turns out no the n95 masks
are not particularly effective at
stopping you from Catching coid or
spreading coid and it turns out they're
bad for you they're bad for your
health the surgical n95 mask which was
the gold standard has been proven to be
Toxic by researchers from xon book
National University in South
Korea apparently the hanky masks are no
good
either you know I hate to say I told you
so I know a lot of you told people so
with regard to The Masks too though so
the question I have
is how did we know that how did we I
don't have a particularly Advanced
degree I I I barely got out of 12th
grade science class how I don't I don't
know anything about masks I don't know
anything about viruses I'm not an
epidemiologist I don't have lots of
fancy degrees like Mr Drogi who's
probably going to come back to public
life I don't how is it that I and you
and your hi ignoramus hillbilly Uncle
Billy Bob were all much more correct
about the scientific questions than all
the Geniuses with the advanced degrees
at the NIH how is that the
case
because we know that human beings were
not made to breathe into a big hunk of
plastic or cotton or any other kind of
mask all the time I I think that's I
think that's how we knew it cuz we knew
no matter what the advertising said no
matter what the fouches said that human
beings are not supposed to do that
that's not what we're for that's not
what our lungs are for our lungs are not
for exhaling into a mask or inhaling
through some stupid mask we know that's
not what our faces are for we know our
ears are not for holding the mask bands
on we just know that's not
normal and because it's not
normal there's a good shot it's going to
have some negative consequences for us
that I think that's that that was my
thinking at least I didn't look at
studies I think studies are bogus I cite
them when they back up my point but I
think most social science and most
surveys generally are are clap trap and
you have your statistics and I have my
statistics and 152% of Statistics are
made up but we at the very least know
ordinary normal people with even a modum
of Common Sense
know that human beings are not supposed
to act like weirdos all the time and the
libs just incessantly try to get us to
act like
weirdos as a matter of public health in
our schools in our jobs certainly in our
sex lives they're always pushing that
and it's
just if you have any common sense you
know it's just it's probably not good
boy what a great clip that was huh now
make sure that you ring the bell
subscribe to the Michael NS YouTube
channel we'll see you next time